[Music]
you
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to welcome
back to bearish choice my name is Caleb
Denby and I'm filling in tonight for a
Mon Hamilton who's out doing some very
important fundraising for the club
tonight so tonight we've got a few games
planned to go over this first one here
is from someone called Fabien Oates who
is from Germany he is 20 years old and
about 1240 but he hasn't played that
much over the board chess according to
this note here it looks like we're
looking at a chess calm correspondence
game that he managed to win with the
black pieces
despite winning he's not sure how he
played in the late opening or middle
early game so that's what we're gonna
take a look at you know he said it would
be very nice if a GM could analyze it
but I'm the next best thing that the
club has to offer so well that's good
going so it starts off 1.d4 like you
said it's a kings ending and you see
Knight f6
c4 g6 like c3 Bishop g7 efore d6 + f3 so
do you know what opening line this is
so yeah it's a line in the Kings Indian
but this is actually the same ish
defense with f3 so white is saying okay
I know what blacks common plans are
usually black in this opening play
something like f5 and attacks the c4
pawn later on have you seen that before
yeah so White's saying oh whoops that's
not what black is saying white is saying
okay I know you're gonna attack this
pawn I'm gonna support it with f3 right
away you know but black isn't fazed
black just castles Bishop d3 gets played
black breaks with E 5 which is the
common break here white actually takes
on e5 and black takes only 5 what do you
think about this one this capture on e5
for white good move or bad move
okay
might not be good for a white so a lot
of what you just said is pretty correct
so White's forcing black to have this
epon kind of stuck on e5 right and it's
gonna be a little bit weaker now if
black tries to go for this f5 stuff but
of course the big thing that you
mentioned first is that this D file gets
opened right so what that means is
usually you know some pieces are
probably gonna get traded along this
file you know why it might try to use
this d5 square for a knight but
fortunately for black you know you still
has this c6 move whenever he needs to
control d5
so this line usually isn't seen as
playing for too much of an advantage if
I understand my Kings Indian stuff
correctly from the white point of view
so white simply just developed a Bishop
e3 going from here and yet and black
should be fine he just develops his
pieces as well
Knight to c6 is kind of interesting
actually because like I said it it's
kind of you know important that black
has an answer to this Knight d5 move
right and now that the night is on c6
it's kind of blocking its own pawn right
I don't know if that's too apparent but
yeah now something like 95 maybe not
right away but later on could be kind of
nasty for black was something like this
should be Bishop c5 coming attacking the
rook maybe or a Bishop g5 attack or
pinning this Knight either way you know
d5 is a great square and you want to be
sure that you can play C six eventually
to kick the knight out but instead we
saw a three so why just wanted to keep
this night at a beat four which makes
some sense
a5 was played
you know maybe preventing white from
pushing a4 or beef or rather which makes
you know some sense make some sense
b3 mmm this moves a little dubious I
think but I'm sure it's fine it's always
just you know it makes me anxious when
moves like b3 get played with this fee
and cut a bishop and right now it's it's
kind of clear that this pawn is in the
way of any of those ideas but later on
you know maybe we'll see some tactics
where the pawn ends up getting moved you
know of course
mm-hmm yeah there might be just as an
example of how you know one way and this
might get opened up some somehow maybe
why it might have to take here and then
you know after something like efore this
diagonal would be pretty weak so you
just have to be cautious when you play
moves like b3 against a fee and kind of
Bishop one other thing that might happen
is this night might move over to h5 and
try to come into f4 and now white would
like to take this night or be able to
take this night but then again this
would be opening up this Bishop right so
you'd have to be a little bit more
careful now so b3 is not a move you
really love to see as the white player
but maybe you know as the black player
fabien or fabien was very happy to see
this
he just developed his pieces which makes
a lot of sense I would have liked this
Knight h5 move as well but you know it's
it's hard to argue against you know
getting your pieces out and then why
continued with work to be one so he's
really trying to push this B for a
breakthrough which you know that kind of
explains why he played b3 cuz maybe he's
seen you know some games where this pawn
gets pushed to a4 right and then that
kind of stops before forever because of
on passant yes so that's exactly right
so even though white was afraid of that
he really had no cause to be because he
could just move his rook over and black
really wouldn't want to play a for it
cuz you could just take it and then
before what would come through anyways
right
so b3 isn't really a great move Bishop
e6 you know I again just developing your
pieces it's always good I work to be one
is played and now Knight to e so this is
a move I'm not a huge fan of what do you
think I would have liked from black
instead or what do you like from black
instead of 98
mm-hmm
yeah that's right this idea that we just
looked at with 9h 5 and now coming into
f4 could be quite strong right
yeah so like you said this tonight's
gonna be annoying and and if white tries
something like g3 that's actually gonna
be pretty weakening right it's gonna
weaken all these light squares around
his King yeah that's right it's kind of
a hook you know f4 can now be you know
kina can now capture this pawn on g3
when it comes immensely so Knight age
five might have posed some really
serious problems for white right and
ninety eight kind of a similar idea he
still wants to play this f5 f4 but it's
not nearly as strong as putting the
night on h5 in my opinion why continue
with Knight to e2
he's just developing naturally f5 is
played Queen c2 so he just continues
development
it looks like the viewer inputted a line
here with eat X and G takes castles
Knight of 6 and Queen c2 and yeah I
don't know so much about this line for
white I think I like the way that white
played better because like I said now
that he's really weakened this
dark-squared diagonal you've got to be
absolutely certain you can keep control
of efore after you capture on f5 so that
would be you know kind of risking a lot
for white because if black ever gets
this efore move in it's gonna be big
trouble for right because this Bishop is
just gonna you know shine through so
that's why instead we saw Queen c2 but
now it's simply f4 bishop f2 King h8 was
played and
yeah so the idea might be to bring this
rook over bring this bishop back and
then push through right you know it's
kind of a common idea in the Kings
Indian but uh yeah it looks like you
know this Queen g5 I there's a note
written in Spanish which I don't speak a
great deal of but it I do know that this
is very interesting because now White
has to decide something if I understand
these words correctly so yeah how does
white want to you know defend this pawn
it's actually not so easy to tell
looks like the choices the viewer gave
for King f1 or g3 so yeah what would
happen on castles you know something
pretty nasty happens right away
yeah just Bishop h3 right and this would
just be totally crushing yeah I mean you
have to stop mate somehow there's really
no way to do it besides moving the pawn
and then this is hanging and then this
is opening and then this is hanging so
that wouldn't be great
that wouldn't be great so yeah maybe
Queen g5 is quite good I'm not sure what
else white can actually try here cuz I
mean King f1 looks like the only the
only idea what's wrong with ruck g1
maybe he's still this Bishop h3 idea I
guess it is you're right yeah sorry
let's see I guess we're cheating one is
playable but you know you really don't
want to be giving up castling rights in
this manner right it's almost like would
you rather have the King on e 1 or f1 if
you're not going to Castle and I think
f1 is just better but yeah this is
another another way for white to play
and maybe then you can try g3 and G
takes f actually it'd be kind of
interesting yeah I'm not so sure how
black would would want to deal with this
right away
see I've got my chat up here now I don't
know if the chat has any ideas but mmm
maybe black would just retreat like in
the other one simply like 27 and then
continuing with the pawn breaks could be
interesting yeah this this Queen g5
might have been very good because you
know forcing white to give up castling
rights is always strong instead we saw
King h8 in the game white continued 95
so yeah the score is important like I
mentioned and black would love to be
able to play this so maybe that's why I
would have rather seen this night go to
d7 earlier just kind of a minor thing
just to give you the extra option here
yeah in d7 maybe you come into c5 later
on after you kind of reposition your
pieces black wasn't phase though by the
Snowden t5 if he just continued with g5
trying to get g4 in white decided he
wanted to try to stop this which is why
you played h3 and now h5 yeah I don't
think I can translate this sentence over
from from Spanish I'm doing my best but
uh I I don't really know what the viewer
was saying here probably this was left
for Pepe but okay so h5 obviously the
idea is he wants to get g4 it you know
he doesn't have much choice here in my
opinion but the thing is with white unn
castled and g4 might do more harm than
good right so let's you know quickly see
how this continued on here you played
Queen c3 and now I guess black kind of
realized opening up this h-file isn't
really in his best interest right not
with this King on it so maybe that's
another reason why a king AJ it might
not be the the greatest move ever so
here instead we saw v6 hmm I don't know
about this move it doesn't really seem
to do a whole lot right
yeah if I was doing fine and yeah yeah
but you can already move the c6 night
right you don't really have to be
worried about that you can go to e7 if
you want and maybe this is a maneuver I
would have liked to see either 97 or 94
if 97 maybe I'm not sure how why it
wants to continue here
I guess Bishop c5 might be a problem
maybe this is what black was actually
afraid of well yeah this could be
problematic if the problem who takes in
d5 is white simply recaptures on d5
right uh well yeah but you have better
than an exchange SEC if he takes here
right you can just take the Queen yeah
so you know maybe maybe that's what
black was afraid of actually but you
know this 94 move might actually be fine
as well the knight takes the pawn takes
the bishop takes and now c6 this is the
line the viewer put in see Bishop g7 97
this all looks reasonable to me and then
I guess this Knight is actually stuck
Wow
who would have guessed this Knight has
no squares um so yeah that's that's
another reason why you know this this
this idea what the knight hat being on
c6 maybe jumping into d4 it's kind of
interesting but you know blocking in the
C pawn does have its definite downsides
right so okay regardless we saw B 694
might have just won the game because of
this idea I guess you know then white
can't actually capture he has to make a
square for his knight maybe with like
Queen to d2 oh yes so it takes takes
takes
whoops takes and then the c6 move seems
to trap the night right
you can try jumping here but I think
actually uh I can just take this piece
you know takes and takes on c3 yeah um
so okay maybe Knight d4 was amiss but
you know that's kind of a complicated
tactic you can't really blame blame the
guy for not finding that one right away
b6 I guess seems reasonable if you're
thinking of you know rerouting the
knight in this direction and you're
worried about Bishop c5 here Bishop c2
was played maybe he's preparing to I
don't either play b4 or remove this rook
over to d1 which I think would be the
best square for it we see Knight f6 and
now white plays g4 my goodness it's kind
of a crazy move right what are your
first thoughts on on g4
yes so he's trying to lock it down right
he said they're trying to only open the
H file after H takes one you know this
would be advantageous for white
obviously cuz you know he's already got
a truck there or he just wants to shut
down the Kings side completely with h4
which also makes some sense for him so
he doesn't have to worry about the Kings
side you can just continue with this
plan of b4 and use the strong knight on
d5 to his advantage yeah yeah I think so
but unfortunately for black you know
trickiest rule in chess what can black
play yeah on passant obviously right so
F takes G 3 and this gives white some
serious problems right it's opening up
this rook you know it's leaking and it
weakening both of these pawns you know
this pawn is under attack it's really
really not great
whoops press the Windows key all right
it's really really not great for white
so yeah I'd say that after g4 black is
probably just winning let's see how
continued though so Bishop takes g3
let's see black went Knight h7 not sure
this is the greatest square for the
knight but maybe yeah I think you just
wanted to open up this rook and maybe
you know Knight g5 later on but mm-hmm
I might have liked to see h4 what do you
think you know the idea might be here oh
well I guess actually there's another
point in h7 and that's this pawn is
hanging so valid points again valid
points again but maybe I can just take
this it's not so clear to me what's
going on here right
yeah like ticks on d5 and 93 might be
good right
something has to happen with this Bishop
you have to defend it I guess right you
have to play like Rexy one yeah Bishop
d1 I guess is is an option but you know
I mean I'm kind of crashing through now
all right yeah I would play her gift
through anyways I'm actually threatening
checkmate here so I'm really not sure
what Whitewood do about this yeah and I
g2 would be made yeah so I don't think
you know white could take this pawn if
this were to be played so something like
Bishop f2 maybe and then you know I
would just continue with Knight age 5
again this night aged 5 to f4 ideas is
super common in these structures and
it's I think it would be a really great
way for FRIB like to continue here
rather than bringing the night all the
way to h7 right so yeah this this is I
an idea that's you always want to be on
the lookout for in these structures
there's bringing this night into f4 what
line
nitin captures okay so yeah nine takes
g3 mm-hmm you and I don't see anything
wrong with it per se maybe it's still
just age five or H four other do you
want to come up here there's really no
difference if you're coming back to e2
anyways right so not if I would be the
only reason okay
why do you want to throw this in this is
your best piece right I don't think you
want to give up this piece it's really
it's your best piece right
okay so you want to take and play Knight
h5 but I mean you're kind of hanging
this pawn if you're not careful maybe
net f5 down
yeah I mean maybe just take sand and
black can say the structure is really
bad for you right and your King still in
the center you're gonna have some
serious problems
yeah I don't know probably probably just
back would be would be best for white
yeah and we'd then it's the same and
still not h5 is coming like like I said
I think this is just very good for for
black because g4 is really not a great
move but okay in the game we saw NAT h7
opening up this truck h4 was played so
black might or white might have noticed
that you know H for attacking the bishop
was slightly awkward but unfortunately
this does allow g4 so black continues to
just kind of open it up where he has
more space while the white king is in
the center which you know makes perfect
sense so we saw f4 here
he takes f4 was played which of course
this just looks like a blunder right off
the bat
okay I skipped a bit sorry yeah f4 just
looks like a blender right this is just
a one weave tactic yeah I mean why just
loses a piece C maybe F takes G would
have kept the game going on a bit longer
but like I said this is gonna be very
tough for white his King is just
honestly stuck Knight d4 is probably
coming and that's probably gonna be
somewhat devastating if if he can get it
in there our Bishop e5 tactics to look
out for but you know a knight takes c2
might be and I don't know it's
complicated but yeah I don't know it
just this King in the centres is gonna
make White's life really difficult but
yeah in the game we saw f4 and this just
hangs a piece after Knight G 3 we saw 95
Queen e3 work f3 Queen g1 net of 6
bishop d1 okay and so you can't take
this rook because of Knight takes D 3
every night take step 3
and yeah I mean White's just getting
crushed here oh so the work was actually
taken and then I guess white resigned
here obviously the King moves in the
Queens hanging so yeah that was a pretty
well played game from Fabian or Fabian
honestly the the only comments I would
have are one maybe be careful about
putting this knight on c6 I guess there
are some pretty strong ideas with
putting it on to d4 but having the C
pawn be mobile is also you know very
nice having c6 available and then the
other thing is this knight h5 idea is is
usually better than 98 or 97 you know
when you have the choice to come into f4
it's usually you know the right idea
which is why a lot of times you'll see
in this opening this Bishop gets put
onto e2 you know this is like the the
classical mainline and then uh you know
thus Knight actually drops back to e1
here and this is actually mainly to stop
this Knight coming from h5 right so you
know this is a really good idea that h5
it's definitely something you want to be
paying attention to in your games with
that said thanks for sending this in you
know sorry I didn't understand the the
Spanish comments and Pepe I didn't get a
chance to look at it but so I'm gonna go
and move on to the next game almost
there any questions about this one no
all right let's do it
so the next game looks like it's from
dev eats he didn't leave us too much too
many comments but it let's take a look
so the game started efore d5 so we have
a Scandinavian he takes d5 Knight f6 so
black doesn't actually capture the pawn
back right away which I guess is an
interesting line I don't know a great
deal about it all I know is that the c-4
move from white is usually pretty bad
trying to hang on to the pawn yeah I
think d4 is the main line and then like
you said none of the knight takes now we
can bring this pawn up to c4 right and
it's kind of with tempo and white gets
to build a nice little center while
black is moving the knight around in the
game we saw Knight to c3 which is not a
move I'm deeply familiar with um
sure it's it's not terrible though the
night took on d5 and then we saw Knight
takes d5 so this is kind of an
unnecessary trade in my opinion I don't
think white should play like this
necessarily because usually in openings
like the Scandinavian what kind of
structures do you get in the centre you
know who has more central space yeah
white usually gets more space in the
scandi right you know black gives up the
center pawn usually and you know like
this line we just looked at you know
white gets to build a nice Center he has
plenty of space back here and then
eventually it let's just play some moves
not saying they're great you know black
is gonna have less space to work with
for his pieces right he's only gonna
have these four squares pretty much in
the back rank so what should happen in
games where you have less space what do
you want to do yeah so when you have
less space yeah you want to trade off
some minor pieces right because if you
have less pieces then it's less awkward
for them to maneuver in their space so
already you know trading off these
Knights is kind of a victory for black
cuz you know it's one less piece he has
to worry about in his limited space we
saw Queen takes d5 and now Knight f3 so
what's really delaying playing efore
here and I'm not sure it's it's the
greatest idea for him already as black I
would be tempted to play something like
II 5 here you know just taking the
central space that that white isn't
taking and that's a very common idea
that you see in a lot of you know lower
rated games is when one player doesn't
take the center space very often you
know the other players should you know
make his own claim in the center hey
what's up Ben
which color do beat is know he is asking
us from the white point of view though
about the bishop takes f7 move so if I
had to guess I would say he's playing
with the white pieces yeah when you guys
do send in games be sure to leave us a
few notes about you know which side
you're playing you know where you're
talking to us from you know like that
far beyond guy you did a great job we
learned all about him but yeah so this
is an idea to look out for is you
definitely want to grab the center space
while you can
which is why is white you know I really
think the best move here would have been
to play something like d4 or even a yeah
I don't know I think d4 might have been
the best move instead we saw Knight f3
and then black actually just plays a
knight c6 so he's still not taking the
center space and once again I really
would have liked to see d4 here just
preventing black from playing a5 from
taking this space I guess you know
Bishop g4 might be slightly awkward
you can play Bishop e2 though and you
know c3 to follow to you know maintain
the central pawn there's no tactics here
with taking on d4 because white always
heads Bishop takes c6 so yeah you really
do want to grab the central space that's
that's the main idea that's you know
being avoided here instead we saw b3 so
White's gonna try to you know control
the center with this Bishop which is
another way to go about things but I
always prefer the classical you know
control the center with your pawns way
of way of playing especially at lower
level games we saw Bishop f5 simply
developing Bishop c4 gaining time on the
Queen which is nice Queen to d6 d3 you
know so this move doesn't make a whole
lot of sense to me yeah what do you guys
think about this one
yeah it's kind of blocking the bishop
out of its own squares what were you
gonna say
yeah you know the bishops stuck out here
right
yeah so a 6 B 5 might come down the
board
yeah and and so that's that's the other
thing is moving both of these ponds
really weakens these dark squares right
you know these are squares that you know
puns can never really defend from the
white point of view again so you're
gonna run into trouble you know all
along these dark squares if you don't
you know be very very careful
so moving this deep on doesn't make a
whole lot of sense here if you are gonna
move this pawn move it to d4
yeah right I mean this is it's a bit too
late now probably this pawn would end up
being weak but sigh yeah I totally don't
think moving the D pawn is correct here
probably just developing the bishop at
this point wouldn't make the most
classical sense and said okay we saw a
d3 now black finally takes the central
space you finally plays e5 so happy to
see that move white castled black
castled Queen side which makes a lot of
sense and now Bishop g5 is played b5
winds according to Jonathan does its oh
yes so b5 there's actually already
tactic here see a b 5x clinton and then
you know if if white were to take of
course what's the tactic yeah
oh yeah maybe maybe you showed something
like this hopefully we didn't repeat
anything interesting okay
uh yep but okay we'll take a look at
this say yeah okay
so we should be yeah obviously Queen
before is the idea and now Bishop d2
Queen takes b5 and this would be
problematic if Bishop takes f7 has been
suggested what's that looking like it's
still just looking like blacks up apiece
unfortunately taking up seven ponds is
fun in bughouse and real games it
usually doesn't work as well when you're
sacrificing a full piece you can give
one check but the King will run away
maybe two let's see which which square
do you guys like EA Tour g8 yeah let's
go to e e8 maybe Queen age five doesn't
really do anything Queen f3 maybe I can
just move this bishop somewhere maybe I
can just play Queen f6 and maybe just
Queen f6 this just looks fine for for
black I think right
but okay b5 was missed obviously this
makes d3 a terrible terrible terrible
move and yeah Bishop b2 would have just
been better it's like I said though you
know once these dark squares are weak
there's there's definite problems that
show up so okay let's take a look at the
game though like miss this play d5 which
well he missed the tactical win you know
good for him
finally seizing the center white got his
King out of the center finally black did
as well and now yeah Bishop g5 was
played and this move doesn't look so
great
right what do you think about that yeah
okay
yeah okay yeah cuz you know you can play
like f6 right yeah I'm on board with you
kind of see you mentioned you'd rather
put this bishop somewhere like III maybe
where it can support the Kings the Queen
side pawn store and yeah that makes a
lot of sense
you know positionally definitely I might
just start with a four if we were
talking me like purely positional what's
the best way to start the attack maybe
just a four but it looks like there are
actually some some tactical
opportunities for white here so what do
you think you can try
yeah use some opportunities I'm not sure
if they're directly winning but
definitely have some choices here that
you might not have considered
yeah yeah it's good thing it's a good
thing I don't know YouTube chat has any
ideas hmm yeah so that's one choices
just taking this pawn right so yeah the
only problem with this Lin is you don't
get to play two moves in a row right so
you know black can maybe just move this
night over the way
well a six you would just take the night
right but yeah just 94 I think it's just
funny saying a bishop takes up seven is
one idea and this would be kind of an
ambitious try from white well it opens
the F file that's not the main concern I
think the main concern is you know it's
just kind of bringing this bishop
further you know away from home and you
know where where there are loose pieces
there sometimes tactics so maybe already
black could do something like Queen f6
after Bishop c4 maybe something like
Bishop g4 right
[Music]
oh yeah so yes something like a fork it
could happen right all right yeah no so
yeah this Queen f6 move actually looks
looks quite good with with E for I don't
know do I believe it
do I believe it let's see hmm maybe I do
believe it
well actually I think I can just play
queen g6 right and now if you were to
take here maybe I can take on f3 yes you
would have to take back because of the
mate threat on g2 and then I can take
this bishop so this looks pretty good
for black I think
the pieces are pretty coordinated right
this bishops out and this Bishop isn't
out yet but it's gonna have a great
square to come to one on d6 sir can come
to f8 yeah maybe the Knights not doing
its best job but I mean the white pieces
aren't doing great either if we take a
look III mean its first of all it's
defended by the knight for the moment
and we can also just bring this pawn to
c6 if need be and I mean like there are
definitely open files and from the white
king I think I definitely would take
black here for example like I don't know
what move do you want to play as white
here first of all
like just Ricki one
if you had to play move which quite
often interests you do you have to play
moves let's take a look a tricky one so
I'm just gonna develop naturally with
Bishop d6 okay rook e3 I'll just play
York f8 and all of a sudden my pieces
are kind of starting to come together it
is so you have to move the Queen
somewhere right otherwise I'm going to
take on d3 Bishop back to f5 though
yes sure you can play Queenie - I might
make some threats here I haven't decided
threats of which kind but I don't know
well even faster than that maybe I can
play something like Bishop f4 if I want
you might have to come up to e7
I might just play tonight c6 and maybe
your hooks already traps you can you can
check me I might run away yeah okay
maybe you get away just just this once
just this once
yeah okay I mean it's it's not checkmate
maybe this line isn't the greatest way
for black to try
I don't think knight c6 is correct here
but I don't know even for example
something like let's see Bishop g4 even
yeah okay I'll stay Bishop g4
you might do Queeny for maybe right
any objections alright Queenie for and
I'll go ahead and play something like
rent of six since once again like your
pieces are they don't have a lot of
squares to go to and your kings are
gonna be week forever right with the two
bishops definitely black is gonna be
preferred in this position but okay that
was a bit of a tangent so maybe Bishop
takes us seven isn't great another move
to look at here would actually be Knight
g5 I think this was also suggested by
you know the viewer yeah I mean if you
play Bishop e6 like I'm just gonna
capture this right and put more pressure
on the pawn yeah why does the bishop
pair and pressure on you know these
these weak double pawns
I think this should be fun you can play
something like deck to d4 I might
actually just ignore this and and play
you know Bishop b2 if you take here I
might throw in a throw in a check and
then play your xt8 Eric rook c1 rather
and I don't know I think this would be
fine for wait something about the bishop
pair in these open positions as always
you know advantageous so instead of all
that we actually saw Bishop e5 get
played as we first said so something
like f6 might happen or did happen
actually just blocking off this bishop
the bishop retreats to h4 which again
this is really just helping black storm
kind of the Kings side of course the
bishop should come back maybe it's a d2
maybe - III I might like okay I might
like eat three more I might like DT more
I'm undecided either way either those
squares that's much better than h4 so
then g5 comes on Bishop back to g3
and of course h5 so blacks just gonna
storm the Kings side now and why it's
probably gonna end up checkmated h3 got
played
yeah way it's gonna get checkmated ray
oh yeah no he's checkmated not check
meeting so white plate age through here
which you almost never want to move
pawns in on the same side of the board
where you're being attacked but his
bishop was you know threatening to be
trapped yeah it's a hook for black but
maybe white actually had a better way to
try to save his bishop what do you think
no actually I think h4 is pretty nice
and the reason is if you do want to take
and open it up first of all I have a
nice square from a bishop attacking this
pawn it also stops this H pawn and its
tracks kind of and I can maybe play
something like g3 to help just cement
down the position on the dark squares
probably I would first want to make sure
my knight doesn't get pins too badly
maybe a Bishop g4 for example is
actually you know pretty pretty good for
white or pretty good for black right off
the bat but yeah I definitely would've
preferred h4 over h3 because after
something like g4 once this h-file opens
up you know why it's gonna be in a lot
of trouble the bishop came back to d7
the knight jumps into g6 but you know
the rook simply comes up white grabs the
bishop pair but it's kind of too late
for him at this point after rook takes
f3
I believe I've seen the end of this game
already but black found some pretty nice
nice tactics here so how might you go
about playing here
Wow so yeah I guess b5 actually works
here as well that wasn't even you know
what I was looking at but yeah b5 would
win a bishop in the game he actually
threw in this check so how would you
respond to this as white
yeah I mean if you were to play rock up
to then maybe he still has this b5 move
right yeah
Bishop f2 but now black found a very
very tricky move that kind of won him
the game yeah g3 it's pretty sick right
yeah so g3 and now of course what
happens if Bishop takes Queen yeah
there's there's simply no way to stop
checkmate from happening in h1
unfortunately so yeah this this was a
pretty crazy game it looks like in the
game where I actually tried Queen e2
which doesn't survive much longer after
occasion anyways
Bishop takes Queen and her cage won so
yeah what do you think about that game
there are a lot of mistakes made but any
questions about it and I think you're
still confused on No
all right well let's just recap really
quickly so the big things that I would
think the players can take away one
white shouldn't really trade pieces like
this unnecessarily
- they should really you know grab the
center well they can you know white
really should be playing d4 and stuff
like c4 eventually here you know chess
is all about the center as as Jonathan
Krantz will tell you since he's read a
single book or maybe even a single page
out of a single book that's all he needs
to you know be convinced of a new
philosophy number two something like d3
and b3 these moves don't really go well
together right they simply weak in all
of the dark squares and on the Queen
side and that's what led to those
tactics that you saw was something like
b5 coming eventually where you know
already you know the bishop is is being
lost and then the third thing I guess is
a don't help your opponent's pawn storm
like this you know obviously when you
castle on opposite sides you know pawn
storms are going to happen so moving the
bishop out to g5 as you
not great yeah that's that's another
thing is kind of don't overextend your
pieces I guess you know obviously the
specially was just gonna get kicked
around by these pawns so you know it's
not really doing a whole lot for it for
whites position okay so that's that game
and very quickly I'm gonna try to go
over a game from our very own Nick risco
that was played he's here with us for
the moment in the audience so let's see
if he has any explanations for himself
looks like Evan Kelly another Club local
was playing white and Nick was Nick was
blast the Nick was black so we see d4
Knight f6
c4 g6 Knight c3 Bishop g7 so it's
another Kings Indian defense actually
III so this is a you know more of a
conservative way to play the opening
rather than fighting for all of these
central squares and d5 e v you know c5
like this even an f5 white says I'm
simply content with the squares I have
I'm gonna play e3 defend this pawn one
more time and be sure that I can
maintain my pawn center black went ahead
and castled Bishop to d3 both players
are just developing Queen c2 is played
which this move seems fine to me
honestly maybe better is just developing
your last piece well you're almost your
last piece but I don't know Queen C do
seems okay yes so I think these are just
lead just annotations from from the PGN
Nick sent me what's this guy's rating I
don't know Nick what is your rating
these days he's about 1,300 and Evan
Kelly is like 17
1500 Evan Kelly's about 1,500 so
yeah something like that I think
although I feel like I've seen him
before that I don't know
anyways so Queen to c2 okay so back to
the game
you know both players continue
developing black actually went for the
c5 move rather than a five so Nick any
thoughts on that
why did you go for c5 over 85 but you
know maybe best for white is just to let
it sit right so but what made you choose
those plans over the plans that follow
after E 5
it just didn't seem right to try and
push a five and work for f5 interesting
I don't know I would have liked to see
five here I think
you can actually
yeah
yes so if you know black were to play e5
what you're saying is you should play in
the Kings side which is absolutely right
what I'm asking is you know black can
also play c5 which is what Nick did in
the game then obviously these pawns
point the other way but you know the
choice between that I don't think it's
too heavily influenced by you know the
way White's pawns are pointing but you
know here I think you know this this
move would have been good to see and the
reason I think that is because white
didn't take the central space right
so if black manages to take the central
space and that's actually going to be
quite good for him so if you know maybe
he just continues naturally maybe
castles well this never happened right
you didn't play e5 maybe something
simple like Knight to e8 here
and I mean what does white want to do
something like rook b1 could be simple
something like b3 and now I want to
continue with f5 right and I really want
to fight for this central square because
if my opponent's not going to take it I
want to I want to take it myself and
probably something like f3 might be seen
from the white player and this is
already weakening some dark squares so
definitely something to consider this is
another way of playing you know this
this opening this is another kind of a
plan to go for it there's nothing
inherently wrong with c5 though so I
think it's it's fine that you played
that way we saw White Castle rook to b8
aiming for B 5 B 3 a6
Bishop b2 both players just developing
Queen to c7 rook to c1 so black would
like to play b5 here but if you know
white plays some nonchalant move like
Rick a to d1 maybe you know b5 can
already be coming through cuz after
something like takes Nick you're showing
me you know D takes or C takes D maybe
Knight takes D and then actually I guess
you know yeah maybe white can recapture
this pawn if you were to recapture with
the pawn then of course you know black
could take this because of this pin on
the C file you know if if Knight takes
here simply Queen takes
and your tics but okay maybe Knight
takes d4 and you know black couldn't
play this anyways
either way orchid is c1 is a fine
developing move the game continued with
Knight age 5 maybe yeah Eve 5 after
Knight takes but ok we continue with not
h5 this this move it made a lot of sense
with the pawn on e4
it doesn't make quite as much sense with
this pawn in III because this f4 square
isn't really gonna be a future home for
the night it stops the White Knight from
coming to f4 but is that really a threat
I mean what's what's white doing do you
want to come into d5 or something yeah
okay maybe this is something to be
concerned about but I like to stock
fishes solution as you know many people
often do which is just e 6 and you're
just controlling this the central square
right it's all a fight for the center
and a lot of these openings but ok
Knight h5 it's not the worst move ever
and it does stop night at 4 it just kind
of sidelines through night which is
something you usually would try to avoid
95 comes Queen to d8 defending the pawn
Iraq FD 1 Knight d2 f6
yeah I don't know maybe still this e 6
move right makes a lot of sense
9 takes f6 White has tricks would take
the g6 politician
really I don't think you can take this
fun
do you take C okay oh and then yeah if D
take C Bishop takes g6 yeah
oh this yeah I guess this this is kind
of awkward yeah so I wasn't even
thinking tactically but I guess that's
another reason not to play this move
yeah I would have liked d6 here again
really just getting this Knight out of
your face and then uh maybe
repositioning this Queen to get off of
this this file with this with the rook
but okay we saw Knight of 6 d take c5
was played first you inserted Knight
takes d5 probably you were afraid of you
know Bishop takes g6 kind of stuff right
well yeah but you know unconsciously
maybe you're afraid of these discoveries
I'll give it to you
we saw Bishop takes g7 and Knight takes
III so got kind of a weird desperado
here I wonder why you know what happens
if white just takes this pawn this
Knight back yeah now it just seems like
he's winning right
there's no way to wreak regain this pawn
really
yet so maybe your kicks isn't actually
the most accurate because something like
Queen d6 might be fine again if you're
gonna take this pawn though I'm gonna
have some tricks right yet b6 is the
same thing right
b6 I'm still just gonna move okay yeah
maybe he would have b4 there but I mean
Rick c1 is fine this is just still
winning for white because you can't take
this pawn but okay so yeah I guess that
means Bishop g7 is just not a great move
Knight takes c3 it was kind of crazy but
yeah this night before move was
suggested and this looks pretty pretty
good I think if Queens c3 maybe I'm
taking on d3
yeah but this gives you the option to oh
this gives you the option to take on d3
I think which is slightly different
I don't know this is all kind of tactics
let's just go through it so 93 fe3 and I
take she's 7 kind of a weird desperado C
takes D 6 aiming to you know clarify the
central pawn situation Queen takes d6
which seems like it should run into
tactics although maybe it doesn't
well yeah Bishop g6 doesn't work because
of Queen g6 but I mean he has other
options here right yeah Bishop f5 but
maybe even Bishop takes f5 there and the
Queen set maybe there aren't any tactics
but you know black does have to be
careful we see 93 f5 gets played yes so
once again you really want to just step
off this file right
you know why put yourself through all
this this pain and suffering so again
now Bishop takes that 5 does work Bishop
takes f5 Knight f5 Queen e5 and now
Knight h6 and already things are looking
a little a little hairy Yorick d5 here
yeah yeah this this is another move the
Queen will have to move again but I
don't know if it makes a huge difference
let's continue in that h6 King h8 94
Queen g5 queenie forest and simply
centralizing or a5 Queen d4 yeah maybe
it's better just to just to get this
rook in you know just activate your
pieces that's usually something you want
to do
what does h5 do I mean I have like Queen
f4 right I don't know I just activate
your pieces right you're kind of getting
bogged down in specific lines but if you
activate your pieces usually things turn
out all right right I mean just queen up
for here but okay maybe you know white
was afraid of this line so he plays
Queen d4 but this really just shuts out
your own pieces right you want to get
the rooks in the game
h5 was played anyways night just back to
f2 Brooke a f8 attacking the knight so
Knight h3 which again kind of sidelines
the night I guess he's trying to come
into f4 but you know central squares
central squares are very nice
so Knight age 3 Queen age 6 e 4 okay
rook F 1 check and then that's the end
of the game yes so recap one might have
just been a miscalculation I guess it
was a blitz game right it was a fast
game now you saw some Queens c1 stuff
and then yeah it doesn't quite work but
it just hangs a rook yeah maybe the game
would continue it with with something
like this yes so I don't know moral that
story I guess is just keep in mind that
that e5 planned for black and then a
really just y-you know keep your pieces
on loose squares like that Queen on d6
you know you just want to get your
pieces on under safe squares and you
want to activate your pieces from the
white point of view is that's something
a kind of you know missed out on was
just not activating his pieces any other
questions about what happened in that
game anything you were kind of confused
about
yes I yeah I mean Rick t7h five rookie
five it looks like he has queen up four
here maybe I'm missing something but
this looks fine
yeah I mean you just want to get your
pieces in the game right that's that's
something to always keep in mind with
that I think I'm gonna call it here so
thank you guys for watching this is the
first viewer choice I viewers choice I
think I've done in a couple years
I think the first class I did was
actually back on one of my first days up
the club so it's fun to be filling in
again doing this once again and thank
you guys for watching
[Music]